everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comto they're going to be
continuing our coverage of the 2014
Chess Olympiad we're in around 7:00
today country's facing off are Norway
team number one
they have three teams than Sarah the
host country against Germany so Norway
being team number one we're gonna be
watching the World Champion Magnus
Carlsen he's going to be playing the
white pieces his rating is 2877 his
opponents with rating of 2709 is the
German Grandmaster denied itch he's
about 28 years old he's a grandmaster
he's a phenomenal player so definitely
very interesting match to watch we'll go
ahead and get started with Magnus
Carlsen starting out with pawn to d4 we
see Knight to f6 we see the queen's
gamut so pawn here to c4 we're actually
gonna go into the nimzo-indian offense a
very strong defense from black something
the Magnus Carlsen obviously very very
familiar with attacking from White's so
interested to see kind of where this
goes Knight to f3 pawn here to c5 normal
way for black to attack in this position
pawn here to g3 Magnus crossing Getty
grant to fianchetto onto the King set
try to control these light diagonal
squares castle on the King side we see
Bishop e2 g2 is kind of we talked about
pawn taking here Knight recapturing here
these are all book line moves nothing
out of the ordinary yet for both sides
of the board pawn here to d5 striking
the center trying to maintain control of
these light squares we do see a capture
and a recapture and this night right
here on c3 is kind of pinned so it's
kind of awkward for white he really
wants to go ahead and castle on the King
side so it doesn't have his knight
pinned he would like to either take with
his knight or move his knight somewhere
else and just not have to worry about
his this bishop here on before pinning
it down we continue with Queen here to
b3
getting it developed also attacking the
bishop here once this King is Castle
deny can take obviously attacking the
bishop there on a b4 Knight to c6 again
both sides just continue in the
development not too much is going on
magnus carlsen does decide to go ahead
and capture there's a recapture here on
c6 this is an isolated pawn that
has here on c6o magnus carlsen maybe
looking to attack this later on it is
opening up for this outpost here on d5
great central square for this night here
on d5 so Magnus Crossan may want to go
ahead and exchange that off the board
once he castles and it's nice and longer
pin but again he's gonna be fine down on
this isolated pawn especially since he
has the glide squared bishop here you
can have it I down this long Dagon right
here so magnus carlsen decides to go
ahead and castle over here and now we
see the Queen come down here to a5
adding a little bit more support on this
bishop here on b4 the Knight to e4 again
magnus carlsen just waiting for his
opportunity to go go ahead and move this
Knight right here because it was being
pinned down so if we kind of look at
what both sides are looking to do black
is almost completed his development he's
easy his LightSquared bishop involved
into the action he needs to protect his
isolated pawn here on the C file he has
a pretty good pawn structure he needs to
make sure that all of his pieces are
really protecting one another he needs
to get his rook involved he can bring
his rook over here to d8 controlling
this long file bring his rook over here
if he wants here to b8 controlling the
semi-open file white on the other hand
has a few things he needs to do magnus
carlsen really needs to get his pawn
here on e2 activated you want to be
controlling the center of the board with
your pond so pawn here to e4 eventually
needs to come from Magnus Carlsen needs
to continue to control these light
squares with this bishop here on g2 and
then get his dark square Bishop out
involved into the game then bring his
rooks over he can bring his rook over
here to e1 protecting a central pawn
which is gonna be very very powerful or
you can bring his rooks over involved if
he wants to bring it to c1 this could be
a strong move attacking this entire
semi-open file with the square here on
c6 or if he wants to get a little bit
more aggressive and play rook here to d1
later on trying to control this long
file that may work as well so that's
again what we're approaching the middle
game and that's kind of what both sides
are going to be looking at as they
develop into the middle game we now see
the bishop come here to a6 again
developing those pieces as we talked
about it is kind of blocked off from
ecigs and bringing here to b7 isn't
really gonna do anything so really the
only logical square for Knight is to
bring his bishop
- we see the Queen come back here to see
- and then pawn here - age six just kind
of blocking off this opportunity for
magnus carlsen to bring his knight over
here to g5 just doesn't want to deal
with it again there's not too many great
moves for black right now so he's kind
of in the waiting game he does play pawn
here to a3 and this is better you know
you may look at this board and say well
you know the Queen can just take your on
c6 yes he is kind of leaving his pawn
here on e2 which is definitely gonna be
bad you all you definitely don't want to
give up this central pawn right away
from Magnus Crossing but it's actually a
lot worse if you were to try to play
Queen here thinking here on c6 because
rook to c8 is actually devastating why
it's gonna lose his queen there's no way
for white to really hang on to this
Queen he could try Queen here to d7 so
it doesn't get captured right away but
then from here we get to see the Bishop
to b5 adding more pressure now if the
Queen if we kind of look at all the
different moves he could come back here
to Queen to b7
but now rook to b8 and that's kind of
all she wrote for the Queen so Magnus
Carlsen not going to fall for that he
decides a little simpler move and that
is just the pawn here to a3 the bishops
forced to go back here to e7 Magnus
Carlsen starts to be a little bit more
aggressive pushing forward with pawn
here to be for the Queen to b5 still
trying to be active not many great
squares unless he wants to be pretty
defensive and bring his queen back here
Magnus Carlsen rook here to e1 doesn't
want to have to have his queen being the
only piece protecting this pawn here on
e - so it brings his wicker rook over to
add support to that Queen here - a c4 a
little bit more of an aggressive Square
for the Queen Queen back here to be -
Magnus Carlsen not ready to give up his
queen since again he is white he does
have the advantage so far in the game
plan here - c5 is an interesting move if
we got to come back and look at what
Magnus Carlsen wants to do this square
right here is a great outpost for him so
playing pawn here to c5 exactly what
Magnus Carlsen is looking to do
except he gets material in this game so
he takes with his night here on c5 his
opponent now plays Bishop here to f6 and
I don't think he recognized the move
because this this looks okay it says
okay if the Queen's gonna move I'm gonna
take the rook that's gonna be good for
black but what I don't think and nighted
saw is that Queen here to a2 it kind of
stops all that and all of a sudden he
can't really take because he's gonna end
up losing more material so instead he
plays rook over here to c8 pawn pushing
forward to e4 again this very very
deadly move that we talked about now
controlling the center of the board with
this pawn forcing this knight to move
the Knights are gonna come here to c3
magnus carlsen decides to go ahead and
exchange off the board
but then pawn here to e5 and all of a
sudden magnus carlsen is in complete
control he now is up a pawn in material
and his opponent is trying to figure out
where things went wrong he has a nice
little outpost here on c5 so things as
we are in the middle game are definitely
looking very very good for the world
champion Magnus Carlsen so with the see
the bishop come here to e7 bishop here
to d2 magnus carlsen actually just now
is completing his development but he's
been doing other stuff in this game so
Knight here to e2 really only move for
white is to bring his Queen King over
here to h1 he doesn't want to have to do
any sort of windmill where this Knight
just moves all over and the bishop has
undiscovered checks there so we see the
knight come back here to d4 rook over
here to c1 to get any aggressive Square
to control this long file right here
bishop here to d5 magnus carlsen is
completely okay exchanging off material
he's up in material so if he can just
get down to the in game he's gonna have
the advantage and he can easily win this
game the only thing he does have to be
aware of in this particular case is his
opponent now has a passed pawn so this
pawn here on d5 it can eventually be a
problem if magnus carlsen just lets it
be it can start to push forward Knight
it may want to bring a rook over here to
d8 or even this one to d8 kind of his
reinforcements for this pawn start to
push forward so that's kind of
game-playing the night heads if he wants
to have some sort of comeback in this
game we now see magnus carlsen played
knight here to these seven opening up
the C file if 9ish decides he wants to
exchange also attacking this night here
on f8 neither just decides he does want
to exchange it's gonna be completely
okay with Magnus Carlsen as we talked
about he's trying to get down to no
material on board because he does have
the pawn advantage now Rick over here to
d8 the Knights gonna come back here to
c5 but this is a great square for this
night if Knight decides he wants to go
ahead and and take this night off the
board that's going to be fine
the Magnus Carlsen can have a pretty
active rookie who wants to round c5 you
can also just take back with this pawn
here on c5 and that gives him an
isolated pawn past pawn at that so
that's gonna be good as well so a lot of
different options which is exactly what
happened so the bishop takes here Magnus
Carlsen decides to take with this rook
again I think it maybe poses more
threats if he takes with this pawn but
taking with your rook again is gonna be
completely fine East open material his
opponent now plays Knights here to f3
and this is a very interesting spot in
the game because this is a pretty
aggressive Knight it's now attacking
both the bishop and the pawn here on e5
and how magnus carlsen defends this is
going to determine how the rest of the
game plays out in Magnus cross and I
think actually chooses the wrong way he
plays a bishop here to c3 and the
problem with that is if his opponent
plays pawn here to d4 all of a sudden
this stops this bishop from protecting
this pawn all the sudden black and plays
some different moves but this pawn is
not protected by this bishop and that's
not what magnus carlsen wants instead he
could have played bishop here to f4
still a very active square for his
bishop but it's protecting his pawning
he doesn't have to worry about it
getting blocked off and not being part
of the action in the potato game as we
talked about plays Bishop here to c3
and his opponent starts to push forward
with pawn here to g5 still knowing that
this night here on f3 is going to be a
pain for
his opponent pawn here to h3 pawn to h5
again Knight is getting a little bit
more aggressive with his pawns over here
King here to g2 pawn here to G for
adding reinforcements a nice little
outpost for this night here on f3 we now
see pawn here to b5 Magnus Crossin
recognizing you can't do too much over
here on the kingside so he starts to
look elsewhere on the Queen side so
Magnus Carlsen again this position he
has the material advantage who he needs
to make sure he holds onto that material
advantage and also needs to make sure
that his opponent doesn't do anything
tricky with the past pawn here now rook
here to d7 this is going to just a
little bit better position for this rook
it's protecting both of these ponds
right here work up here to see a it's
not really doing too much the King can
just come here to h7 a bishop here to a5
trying to get more involved into the
action but then all of a sudden NIDA -
plays pawn here to d4 starting to put
more pressure on his opponent pushing
forward with this pawn right here we now
see an exchange off of pieces but that's
gonna be completely fine nothing changed
too much on board but all of a sudden
this knight he can really start to
attack the square here on e5 there's no
more protection as far as ways Magnus
Carlsen can kind of defend this he could
play rook here to c7 if he wanted to
this is one way if there is the knight
capturing right here we can now see the
pawn come up here to a4 we could see the
rook take here on d7 after the knight
captures then the bishop could come back
here we are even in material but this is
going to be completely okay when there's
bishops on boasts or pawns on both sides
of the board the bishops are usually
going to fare a little bit better than
an opponent's knight so if we kind of
look at that there's some pretty good
options I think Magnus Carlsen has on
board but he plays a crucial mistake and
he plays pawn here to e6 and he just
gives his opponent that pawn right here
he doesn't advance his board state at
all his rook over here on c8 still is a
little bit less active Knight it isn't
rook here on d7 is way more active it's
protecting this past pawn here on d4 and
all of a sudden magnus carlsen finds
himself in a very big disadvantage we
now see rook to c7 it's a little late
though because now this pawn can just
push forward with d3 and it's much
further down this line than it was in
the previous line that we talked about
so again as we said before black really
needs to come down here and start to put
pressure on Magnus Carlsen and that's
exactly what he does now the king is
forced to come over here to f1 try to
add a defender we now see tonight to a
d4 this is kind of stopping some of the
threats that white has King to e1 and 9s
decides that he's gonna go ahead and
give up his pond but he's just gonna
capture all of his opponent's pawn so
bishop back here to b8 he's gonna gobble
up some material and start to push
forward with a 5 so this is gonna be a
new threat that he has it's a little bit
tougher for Magnus Carlsen to defend
both sides of the board so black decides
it's gonna be easier to give up his
central square which is a little easier
to defend from Magnus Carlsen give that
up take more material on board and then
have this past pawn on the a file which
i think is the definitely the best way
to go all of a sudden black is up and
material and he has a huge advantage
with his pawns
so now he's gonna get his King involved
into the game and start to push forward
a little bit more the good thing for
Magnus Carlsen though is he does have
the dark square bishop and you always
want to have the color bishop that is
where your opponent's going to Queen so
this pawns get eventually gonna come to
a 1 and Magnus crossing can stop that
all he has to do is control this long
diagonal right here and he's going to
control this square right here so that's
definitely a plus for Magnus Carlsen we
see Knight to c4 attacking bishop to c3
again just more of a central square that
he can control still this square here on
a1 pawn here to a3
King over here King to h5 and then we
actually see an either bigger mistake
from Magnus Carlsen and he plays pawn
here to f3 huge mistake because pawn
here to e5 is a huge blow to Magnus
Carlsen
he's forced to now come up here to e4 it
he needs to control this square here on
f3 he can't let his opponent just take
right here after Knight to d6 this is
kind of the dagger he would really like
to play King takes here on e5 but then
after the pawn takes on f3 there's no
way for white to stop this again Magnus
Carlsen does not control the bishop that
would control the square here on f1 and
so this would be a lost call so he's
forced to play just the King back here
to e3 and now the king can come here to
g5 we do see a exchange but now it's
just more pressure he's gonna be able to
gobble up all these pawns over here and
just starting to push forward so King
back here to d2 Knight to b5 Bishop up
here some materials gone now this Bishop
is doing a good job it's protecting this
pawn here on a g3 it's also protecting
the square here on a1 but it can't
protect them a forever the King comes up
here to f5 attacking the bishop is
forced to come back here and all of a
sudden this Bishop can no longer defend
all the squares it needs to after the
King captures here on G 3 then this
Bishop is just forced to come back here
to a1 it can't do too much and Magnus
Carlsen is forced to resign knowing that
this pawn can just push up here get a
queen and easily win the game so
shocking upsets for Magnus Carlsen to
lose to the German Knight it's a very
strong player but definitely not in the
caliber that Magnus Carlsen is in being
the world champion for most normal time
blitz time and bullet time he's just
kind of the best out there so again
great match Magnus Carlsen Falls and
with the white pieces which is even
crazier his first loss with the chess
olympiad but all in all still fun match
to cover so hopefully you guys enjoy
this video a lot more coverage if you
want to check it out on the chess
website we have an entire section
dedicated to more videos of the chess
olympiad but hopefully you guys enjoyed
I'll see you guys in the next one thanks
for watching